The solution to this compound inequality is from negative 5 to negative 2. When
we solve compound inequalities we need to solve each of the inequalities
independently and since they're connected with an AND, we're going to need to
look at the intersection of these two solutions. So let's solve this inequality
first. I'm going to subtract 2x from both sides which gives me negative 1 is
greater than. 2x plus 3. Subtract 3 from both sides, negative 4 is greater than
2x, divide both sides by 2, and I get negative 2 is greater than x. It's
important to know that negative 2 greater than x is the same as x is less than
negative 2. So we have the solution to our first inequality. Let's solve our
second inequality. This time I'm going to subtract 3 x from both sides. When I
subtract 3 x from both sides, I get 2 x plus 3 is greater than or equal to
negative 7. Subtract 3 from both sides, and I get 2x is greater than or equal to
negative 10. Once again divide both sides by 2, and I get that x is greater than
or equal to negative 5. Now that I've solved both inequalities, I have to see
where these intervals overlap. I'm going to use a number line. I'm going to draw
the solution to the two inequalities on top of this number line. X is less than
negative 2 uses a parenthesis. And the solution is less than negative 2. And,
for x greater than or equal to negative 5, I have a square bracket at negative 5
and my solution. Goes to the right. Since this is an AND inequality, we have to
look at where these two intervals overlap. As you can see they overlap from
negative 5 to negative 2, so I can draw the actual solution on the number line,
which means from negative 5 to negative 2 and everything in between. Let's try
another compound inequality.